all right
Stephanie Stephanie where you from
originally where' you grow up um I was
born in New Jersey I grew up here until
I was like 12 years
old and then my mom and remarried and
she moved us out to
Pennsylvania but I my family is from uh
New Jersey and you're back in New Jersey
now yeah I came back to New Jersey when
I was
27 my father was dying from a colon
cancer and honestly I
just when I moved to Philly and when I
left Philly I was a different person
when I went to Philly I was 21 years old
and then that's when I I got really bad
on drugs and I basically was like on the
streets in Philly for about three
years and then when I came to New Jersey
I literally felt like I came out of a
third world country it's such so
different than you know North
Philadelphia you've been there right
Kensington MH it was just crazy it was
like I wasn't the same person it's
almost like it took a part of my soul
heroin like I'll never feel whole ever
again even when I've detoxed got clean
I'll never be that person I was it take
something from you I don't know how to
explain it how old are you now I'm 39 39
mhm and it's been going on since I was
16 years old I've been addicted to
heroin you've had times where you were
clean uh jail
jail Jail's the way clean yeah but it's
not the right way to do it no no but you
get by hook or by crook whatever it
takes to get clean yeah you got to stay
that way though I know that's why I'm
you know that's why I go to the I'm I'm
on the methodone Clinic it does help me
uh financially and legally financially I
don't have to spend all my money on
drugs cuz I do have the methodone and
legally I'm prescribed and I can't get
arrested for it and it does help
tremendously it really does people say
you're replacing one for another but
that's just they just don't know what
they're talking about because but you
still use as well oh yeah I do yeah I I
still use yeah I do and I've been doing
it the
past I guess the the past year and a
half I was I started using every day and
I I do because
the it's so strong the the the fentanyl
is so strong
that it overrides the methadone you know
what I'm saying and it's just like I
don't know I just can't get it out of my
head it's like I try not to but then
like I get
Restless you know I don't know if it's
here or if I'm sick I think it's more
mental now you know what I'm saying cuz
I shot up for [__] I've been addicted to
Opus probably it's been like 14 years
now
um I'm
tired you you know what was your lowest
point when I had the
baby I had a baby uh 5 years ago and
I was doing drugs the whole
pregnancy and then um the entire
pregnancy I was doing
drugs and then I I had to go have the
baby so I went to the hospital and I had
a
probation felony warrants and uh I
didn't go to the doctor the whole night
mon thank God he was okay and then they
Hospital R ran me for warrants and then
the sheriff's came in and they
handcuffed me to the hospital bed and
then I left from there and went right to
jail right after I had the baby and I
did six months I had uh drug charges out
in um Ocean County I got I started I
started getting in trouble when I moved
to New Jersey by the way I didn't have a
record till I was 27 go Philadelphia is
Lawless and I came here and I just
started getting in trouble and um I was
just in and out of jail in and out of
jail but this last time when I had the
baby it just I had no fight left in
me I didn't have any fight left I
just I remember being so
sick cuz literally I feel like heroin
it's almost like a demon has your your
your body it's like it's like a a
sickness and I
remember in I was in the shower and I
just like I was I was sitting in the
shower I was so sick and I remember
praying to
God to
um to take this thing out of me I don't
want to cry in the interview so
hard because I know
it consumes my
life and it ruins my
life and it's hard did you lose the
baby yeah baby was
adopted I didn't want any I I'm not I'm
not the type to have
children I'm not motherly I don't know
why but I don't know how to be
you
know what was your childhood like
um my my mom and dad they drank the
drugs the part you know how parties were
in the 90s I was raised around that my
dad uh he sold meth when I was really
young but my parents they would get they
my mom would leave for days she he would
pass out drunk and she would steal money
out of his pocket or steal the rent
money and then she would be gone for
like the whole
weekend and she would come home and then
my dad used to used to beat my mom and I
think I was like 6 seven and he used to
hit her like it was like it was bad the
cops would get called he got arrested a
bunch of times and I was just uh you
know partying drugs it was just
something that I was raised around I
didn't realize when I was that young
that it's not normal and then I got um I
got older I when I was like uh 10 my
they split up and then I started I
stayed with my father until I was 12 and
then my mom called DHS on him because he
wasn't watching me because I was I was
bad kid I was getting into trouble I was
doing even was 12 years old even kids my
back in the day we were different we
were bad kids back then and I started
doing drugs and and experimenting and
drinking when I was 12 years old and
and I think I when I was um I went to go
live with my mom when I was 13 because
life was got involved and then I moved
to Pennsylvania and that's the only time
in my childhood that was normal was my
Mom married my
stepfather he he was he was a good man
you know what I mean and from like 13 to
17 it was somewhat okay but it was still
it wasn't better you know what I'm
saying my mom's an alcoholic you got
drunk all the time she was she's not a
loving mother you know um you know I was
very I rebelled a lot I'll be out for
days you know uh uh I started doing like
ecstasy acid cocaine when I was like
145 and then when I was 16 I'm I came to
visit my father in New Jersey and the
kids in Mystic Islands were hooked on
Heroin
kids oh my all the the kids were Heron
addicts and my dad when I went there
he's like there's this dope going around
don't do it and I I didn't like it at
first it frightened me cuz they look
creepy like your pupils get pinned like
you just look like a zombie how old were
the kids that were doing drugs yeah oh
yeah we I was like uh fif they were we
were like 14 15 16 and between 14
because I was 16 when I started doing it
but there was like 15 year- olds and 14
year olds it was 14 15 16 they were
teenagers and they're smoking it or
they're uh sniffing it and then shooting
it my friend Valerie got hooked on
Heroin when she was 13 years
old it's it's crazy and then um I
remember I got bored one night because I
didn't have anything to do and I wanted
to hang out with my friends so I stole
$20 from my father and I regret this
till this day I got I bought heroin with
that
$20 and when I did
it I couldn't stop thinking about
it I could not leave it alone I tried
but I couldn't it was the only thing
that made me
feel
good you know I was very lost as a as a
as a kid and as a teenager I was very I
had no
guidance you know what I'm saying did
you feel loved by your mom no didn't
take long to answer that
one she don't care
she never
did I forgave her I'm not angry at them
no more I'm an adult
now I don't particularly want to talk to
her but I did forgive her and my
father you know they hated each other so
much that they hated their own
children [__]
up and then
um yeah by 16 I started using in heroin
and then I got off of it when I was 19 I
got
pregnant and I did get clean for them
two years and I had my baby my my
daughter is 17 and
um I didn't do drugs with
her her father was mentally abusive and
and physically abusive he was he was
just rotten to me when I got pregnant he
just he just wanted nothing to do with
me
and it broke my
heart that
hurt and then I and then that's when I I
started doing heroin again and then
that's when it
happened that's when it took over me
that's when it was the only thing I
cared about I I just would want to think
about anything I just wanted to block
everything out and now that your heroin
has is fenel yeah that makes it even
harder to quit yeah it's hard and I my
my sister I'll talk a little bit about
my siblings you want me to sure my
sister was 12 years
old um she robbed a house with guns and
she TR I don't know she got in trouble
for it though in Pennsylvania she she
got sent away she got arrested at 1200
got sent away at
13 she got out at she got out at 16 and
then my dad's
girlfriend got knocked up at like this
is like crazy tell story my dad's
girlfriend got pregnant by the guy at
the tattoo
po what I did she did the same thing
when she got pregnant she hid it she
didn't tell no one so then she had the
baby and then DHS got involved because
my dad my my mom got divorced from my
stepdad and she went crazy she started
smoking crack partying even partying
with me my parents do drugs with me and
party with me and she like lost it after
the re the divorce and then she she uh
abandoned my sister at a hotel my sister
Samantha and I went and picked her up
and I brought her to my dad's and then
my dad was okay for a while but then he
got all [__] up on um oxy KS he was a
drug addict and um when she got pregnant
I'll go back to that when she got
pregnant same thing happened DHS got
involved and they started going to the
house and they said either she goes or
the kids go and he chose his girlfriend
and said take the
kids this is this is
true and um she got they put in foster
care and then they she got out at 18
when she got out that was a mess I was
in no no state to try to help anybody
and then she got all [__]
up and all four of us have had a rough
life we we never we all we had if have
is each other like we don't where's your
sister now Samantha she her and her my
her and my brother murdered her husband
in self-defense she's in a battered
women's program in Tennessee and my
brother gets out of prison in
2024 yeah the guy was abusing my sister
and beating her
like it was sickening he tied her up one
night like he would choke her and it was
just like it got so bad that that she
got pregnant by
him and then the night when the murder
happened my brother just got out of
prison when this
happened they've been institutionalized
their whole life I was lucky I was 18
when DHS got involved and the kids so
they couldn't take me and um they've
been institutionalized their whole life
that's all they this it's just like a
life of crime for them you know I'm I'm
a little bit more rational I've wouldn't
have done that I probably would have
just left or called the cops because I'm
not that type of person but everybody
handles stuff differently and her my
brother and him started fighting he got
M with my brother there and and my
brother and him started arguing and
fighting and my sister went in the
kitchen and grabbed a knife and came up
behind them and stabbed
them and killed them and they left them
there and then they ran out the house
and they came to New Jersey and I'm like
what the [__] I got homicide I got my
cousin called me asking going where's
your brother and sister and I said I
don't know why well they murdered her
husband and I'm like what I'm like what
the [__] I was like this is crazy I was
like what the f it was just like
something that you see on TV that you
don't think it's ever going to happen to
anybody you know do you know what I'm
saying and she got she documented the
abuse I had pictures in my phone of her
beat up
and she documented it so she she it got
bumped down to manslaughter and then the
Jud she's so lucky she had these high
priced attorneys and I said Samantha how
the [__] did you get these attorneys and
she goes they take uh five murder cases
a year pro bono and her case was the
fifth one that landed on their
desk I said that's the grace of God I
said you know how lucky you are cuz if
you had had a public defender you'd be
in prison right now they fought for my
sister they looked at the case and said
there's something wrong here you know
what I'm saying and they fought for her
she's going to you know how like a sex
Defender has to like be on there for 10
years and it's not she's not a sex
offender but she has probation for 10
years like she did kill somebody you
know what I mean they have to monitor
her and see you just she did kill
someone her my brother my brother maxes
out though he gets out in
and this is it's just crazy
man it's it um it's crazy my I I've
lived a crazy life I'm just
now I'm doing a little bit better but
I'm not better you know what I
mean were there things you want to do
with your life that you never get a
chance to yeah like what heroin stops
that I I wish I would have went to
school I didn't go to school when I was
young I didn't even go to 10th grade I
never never went to school ever never
went to school and so high school you
went one year and that was it
yeah yeah I I dropped out and I just did
not care about my future see when you're
young you really think you're going to
be a teenager forever you don't realize
that how quick it goes
by and I just didn't never cared about
nothing I never cared about myself I
just didn't care I just I didn't want to
care because I didn't want to get
hurt so I try not to care you
know what's your biggest
regret not being there for my
daughter and being a mother to
her and doing
heroin you know I do regret I do regret
that I try to talk to her
but do you feel like it's the lack of
love that you had as a child that is set
you on this path well the reason I
started doing her own when I was young
is because I I thought maybe my parents
would care and they
didn't I wanted to see what they would
say they didn't
care they never cared about any of us it
was so
hectic it it was crazy when I was a kid
I remember the parties man it going for
days doing drugs but one thing I never
did was did I never did drugs in front
of my daughter
I'll never do that I'll never do drugs
with my daughter or in front of her
because my dad was more of like a friend
than a father do you know what I
mean when I was 27 I that's when I
started to prostitute sell my body for
heroin because I didn't know what to do
when I'm sick and it was like I did that
for a while I
prostituted probably until
2015 and then I stopped and I didn't
want to do it no more
my priorities now I still do drugs but
I'll pay my rent before I buy drugs I'll
take care of my bird before I buy drugs
and I try to I don't think I'll ever be
sober I'm just not that type of person I
don't have that type of willpower to be
sober you know what I mean and I I'm
being honest you know I'll be on Myro
for the rest of my life until the day I
die cuz when you're on this drug for so
long you go go through the physical part
but then mentally you're a little off
like
it like I was like I don't know what to
feel I remember when I was locked up in
Essex County and the psych said well
what do you feel and I said not much of
nothing like anything I don't know what
to feel and he gave me some kind of
medication but I stopped taking it when
I left the um the
jail yeah I'm just not right mentally I
get I have I I think I have PTSD I've
been through a lot my my when I lived in
Philly my my boyfriend was
murdered he got shot to
death
and it
hurt it hurt me
bad he's only new out there you know he
was my best friend and he got murdered
and that hurt that hurt so bad that's
when I I just didn't care that's when I
was just like [__] it and I just started
running the streets doing
drugs prostituting just not caring about
anything but there was always always a
part of me that didn't want to do that
but when I did I forgot to say this not
many not many people say this but I did
heroin before I knew what a peruso was I
didn't know what pills were I did heroin
before I knew what a goddamn oxy was
anything and when I first did heroin
this is what I told myself and it sounds
crazy but I
said this is what I want when I get
older I don't know why I said this I
want to be a heroin addict I this what I
said I this is a life I asked for as a
child and I have not today to this day I
don't understand why I wanted that when
I was a teen why did I ask for this why
did I do parents doing it though yeah
and I said this is what I want I want to
feel like this all the time I said to
myself I want to be a heroin addict and
then I get older now and I'm like it's
just not knowing
kids don't they think they're grown but
they're not teenagers you're not grown
you have no clue what the real world is
like got no [__] idea I said that to
my daughter I said you got no clue what
this real world is like Aaliyah cuz she
lives with his
parents and you know they're good people
they don't do drugs or anything like
that his mom and dad I think his mom's a
nurse and his dad like Rand cities in in
Center City I mean ran businesses in
Center City so like
they took good care of her they just
took care of her they took aan and they
just took care of her they never asked
me for nothing I I if I I just left them
alone they left me alone I stayed
away I chose to stay away because I
didn't I cuz I was all [__] up on
drugs and it was
like I literally was like you would have
thought I had no
children I regret it now though
I wish I would have done a lot of things
different but you know what I look at it
this way if it wasn't for what I've been
through I wouldn't be who I am
today I I'm I have common sense I'm not
naive you know what I mean not not naive
at
all but you see a lot of stuff when you
live on the
street and you know what I always used
to tell myself I would say
there's people in this world that have
it a 100 times worse than I
do and my life is where I make
it and that's what I used to tell
myself you know it can't be that bad CU
there's people in this world that I'm
I'm still here I was one of the lucky
ones that made it out of Philadelphia me
and my sister you know I could be dead
but by the grace of God I'm not and I'm
here for a reason you have a roof over
your head now my my my well he's not my
husband my fiance I call him my husband
because we've been together for nine
years I got with Matt when I was 29
years old I just got out of
jail
and I got with Matt
and I I love the man he's a good
man not just so hard to find some good
man you know what I mean he's a
hardworking man he's older than me he's
54 and I'm
and he loves me and nobody ever gave a
[__] about me nobody ever cared about me
and he cares about me and he's a he's
good I'm so grateful to have him in my
life because if I didn't have him in my
life I wouldn't have anything he
financially takes care of me right now
and you know what he doesn't even
complain about
it you know
what's your biggest fear
now losing
him yeah it's important to have somebody
that that loves you that you love
yeah I don't I don't talk about this
stuff I'm
sorry
I usually just keep it
in your parents where are they now my
mom is in West Creek I don't talk to
her she's an
alcoholic my dad is
dead he's dead he died uh oh God he died
12 years ago from
cancer you have three siblings yeah my
my sister Sarah samtha and Peter my
sister Sarah she lives in Philly she's
actually doing good she got she's
completely sober but she didn't do it
like I did you know what I mean how many
of you were using
drugs
um all of us were using our herin
addicts at what point all four of us
yeah we're her all four of us are heroin
addicts yeah my sister's clean my S
sister Samantha she's still battling
with this with the stuff you know she's
taking subs or whatever the Hell she's
doing but still doing it you know what I
mean if she could right now if she
wasn't in that program she'd probably be
doing heroin still too you know all four
of us more heroin
addicts I grew up on the street I grew
up with no guidance no nothing and it
was just like free-for-all for me
and it it [__] you up in the head after
a while you know I don't have any social
skills I don't have any friends I don't
ever leave leave my apartment and I
don't want friends I don't want to be
around anybody I I hate it I don't I
want to look at anybody I just can't
stand people anymore you're a nice
person though I I like you but some
people it's just like you can't I don't
trust
anyone you
know I have my birds I love my birds
Matt got me my my my birds they're my
babies I felt bad for them because what
kind of birds I have a son Kanye and I
have a little white Budgy and I got him
because I told you I've been in
jail and I feel bad they were locked in
a cage and I said I'm going to change
this little guy's
life I said I want to take him home and
Matt bought me the bird it was like 800
and he said you got to take care of this
stuff this is this is a parot you're
getting I said I'm going to do it I want
to take care of them and I did I trained
them my my one sister goes how did you
train a parrot I said that's just
ignorance if they didn't look it up
parrots are one of the most intelligent
animals they're as smart as a dolphin or
a great eight parrots are very
intelligent so that makes them very easy
to
train you would think they're he's so
animated like they're little cartoon
characters yeah he talks he argues when
we he comes on car rides with him I take
him to my grocery his grocery store he
sits on the steering wheel with mattch
driving and he you know what he did
teach me though patience you got to have
patience when you deal with them you
know because they're like it's like a
four-year-old child that flies and poops
and and squaws because of how smart they
are and so it's like every morning's a
routine but they taught me to be patient
cuz I was never patient
before and it's like a form of therapy
for me in a way I just I love my bird so
much I mean everything to me Stephanie
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life don't
take anything for
granted you could be gone at any minute
appreciate stuff kindness don't use
people you know be sincere
and tell the
truth even if they don't like it even if
it's bad for you you always I don't lie
I'm not a liar I don't deny anything
about what I did every body knows and I
don't hide it and I don't care what they
think you know and I I I'm very open
about it I was open about it before but
I don't need to be how I was before
though I I'm trying to change I'm I'm a
work in
progress cuz in part of me wants to but
you know what I just don't know how to
it's
hard I remember when I was pregnant I
was prostituting and I got
raped I got raped that's the only time I
ever bet anything happened to me I was
seven months pregnant
prostituting and I got
raped and then afterwards he said I
saved my own life cuz I didn't fight
back and um I'll never forget that
night Stephanie thank you so much for
sharing your story all right we're good
we're good all right thank you darl
you're
welcome